you know how are these brands building
their own identity how do they become
meaningful to a consumer how do
consumers feel like that should be what
you let me call them love marks right we
all have love marks in every product
category whether it's computer you shoes
you're sure your hat your watch your you
know in cannabis those love larcs having
been develop you know to get the
consumers minds and again it's not
rocket science but marketing does work
if it's done well it's a true strategy
right and it's targeting and again you
can't what you do in Southern California
isn't gonna work in Oklahoma right if
you're a multi-state operator or what
you do in Southern California not even
work in Northern California I mean
saying so you're gonna you're gonna
think about adapting to market
conditions the household income what
this ities I mean you can get costly and
then put there's ways to do it that you
can do repeatable assets but add a
little bit of local flavor it's a brand
based on trusting quality and education
and holding new consumers handle
curating experiences for them I would
say our platform flowery time.com is
kind of our long game someone's opinion
me contradict yours way my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we in what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sakia we are on-site
at the beautiful new West Summit the
cannabis tech conference we are now
gonna be talking to Dean waters ID or ul
thank you so much for coming on our show
yeah absolutely really appreciate it
super pumped for this deans background
for those that don't know he's been
executing successful media and marketing
strategies for a variety fortune 500
companies for over the last thirty years
and most recently he's founded flower
town platform and flower town agency to
educate new consumers entering the
marketplace and also give cannabis
brands the proper marketing tools for
normalization Dean I'm so pumped to jump
in all right let's talk about first on
the strategies for successful media and
marketing that you've been doing the
last 30 years and also how that has bled
into flower town
do it now yeah well you can imagine that
media marketing strategies have changed
over the last thirty years because there
is a time where there is a you know a
cable box and that's where you consume
media and that's how you watch
television rating points were kind of
decent and now you're dealing with like
massive fragmentation right so media and
accountability is greater than it's ever
been I you know I worked in the cable
industry for gosh well I started my
career as a media buyer in like 89 90
was super yeah I'm gonna go to college I
was gonna go to a college and then I
decided he was either trying make some
money just super aggressive as a young
person or go away to school and I took
the option going to make some money I
was fortunate enough to work for a
mentor that young age and then from
there I parlayed that experience into
work in the cable industry I work for
the first cable interconnect in the
country which was the first time a cable
company would consolidate a market place
to compete with the broadcast station so
that was called a blink joined add link
in 1991 and it was the first
interconnect in the country that would
consolidate a market place like the LA
Media Markt which is five counties which
is 65 cable systems with a single feed
to compete with broadcast stations
groundbreaking at the time and every
market now has an interconnect but again
viewing has changed over the years after
that I left my corporate job I was there
for roughly 14 years and it was a part
of a startup called local television
network ltn modeled after City TV from
Canada I was there for roughly two years
I was a part of the team launching this
it was super interesting it failed for
all the wrong reasons but it bit me as
an entrepreneur so from there I decided
not to ever go back to my corporate job
I proved myself and to others that I
could actually I that short stint those
two years at local television network is
actually really impactful for me
personally but also showed me a path of
doing things with big big brands without
needing to be selling MTV so I started
my own company called vim B I spent the
first year working in my office of my
mentor who was my first job in media
and I was there for about a year
building my deck building my business
model started hiring a couple people
personally I self-funded the company for
about three years to roughly two and a
half years and from there I I had a
train so it was a time where like manny
and ripe TV and VBS which was vice now
but VBS back then everybody was
imploding they just you know video in
the web wasn't happening brands weren't
sponsoring and then I met Mark Burnett
and Mark Burnett was fascinated by the
business model that was building and in
Burnett you know Mark Burnett the voice
survivor the apprentice Burnett met me
and he was fascinated and enamored by my
business model of like he could never
pull off these type of production to be
a foyer into culture in America at the
time vim B was a destination website for
lifestyle so we were huge in action
sports and music in indie rock hip hop
street art car culture super interesting
fine a lot of my passions growing up in
Los Angeles and we were we would do even
a million views in a couple hours but it
wasn't happening I'm VIN B it was
happening in my space and every blogger
but I couldn't run ads and it was a you
know it was a tough tough time to try
and build a platform
long story short met Mark Burnett within
nine weeks I became the Mark Burnett
content studio and literally overnight
we became this crazy brand studio I
abandoned then B as a destination which
in hindsight was a mistake I should have
kept with it based on where you know
vices today and some of these other
competitors that have built content
companies but regardless I had this
crazy run with Burnett for about nine
years I learned a ton I literally became
the gold standard for content and
digital and series at the time and
really kind of worked with some of the
biggest brands in the world
we just had an incredible run and then
December of 16 Mark Burnett got
purchased by MGM MGM made us an offer
quite wasn't where we thought our
valuation was we made them an offer
about our equity back and it freed me up
to go after cannabis and and I had
started exploring cannabis a year prior
and had some ends with some friends that
were consulting big big brands and you
know got enough information enough
knowledge to kind of you know do my own
thing kind of be dangerous there's
people I met that I just we didn't align
as far as just what I needed to do what
I want
and it wasn't about for me it wasn't
about money it was about insight and
connections in the industry so I went
off and I kind of recruited my own team
some of the best creatives and
strategist that I've known in the
industry and at the time VIN B which was
my core company still in existence I
stepped out I raised some money and a
hard new team and I put some new
executives in place it then B so that I
could again step out and do my own thing
so in December of 18 or she's me January
of 18 we went out and raised some money
and I recruited my team everybody came
on board and March of 1834 town flower
town is a brand that took 12 months to
build the first twelve months was really
about building the brand building kind
of art what we're gonna stand for our
mission didn't come till 8 months later
as far as where we ended up it's a brand
based on trusting quality and education
and holding new consumers hand I'm
curating experiences for them I would
say our platform flower town calm is
kind of our long game you know there's
all sorts of opportunities that we're
getting along the way I should take a
step back then June of this year I
solidified my next round with cohn
reznick who's my name partner who is one
of the largest professional services in
the country
they're forward-facing in cannabis they
you know cannabis is their you know it's
massive growth for them but they have so
many a sustainable energy affordable
housing some really really big
categories for them
cannabis is new but their growth
trajectory is amazing and they're doing
business with over 160 plant touching
brands so creates a really interesting
opportunity for us to collaborate with
them some of the brands they're working
with and kind of mine some marketing
opportunities with some of those players
so we you know in March of this year we
want consumer facing in flower town calm
its again it's a marathon its building a
platform is not easy we also launched
our creative services and some things
that really got no effect May of this
year leading into June and and so we're
working with brands we're kind of built
this toolkit to help brands reach new
consumers we're also you know so within
the flower 10.com platform we've
launched a product directory which is
products that we endorse and brands that
we endorse that we like
the next phase of that is brands coming
in and subscribing to our brand pages
right now there's a bunch of product
pages now it's kind of bringing a really
kind of you know informational approach
to the new consumer to empower them
acknowledge about these brands and then
we have a dispensary directory which
should be launching in the fourth
quarter which it's right now there is
one on flower town the new ones
launching to look more like Zagat's now
Yelp a little more premium and a really
good experience for the consumer and you
know we've social media obviously sheets
for everybody we launched an influencer
Network we aligned with chemical open in
Florence that has the engine that we
need for you know for post mortem our
you know data for clients delivering all
the data they would need all the
analytics that they need and we can give
guarantees which is exciting in the
industry hasn't been used to that today
and we've kind of created a consumer
journey that's safe for influencers to
get involved in canvas brands through
education so flower time comes in as an
educational component and from service
say oh my god I discovered this topical
it's amazing for muscle recovery I find
it on flower town calm check it out
swipe up you arrive in a story about
this topical based on fitness and so if
you want to show up you can click and
then you'll go to that product page
where you can find it dispensary to
purchase that project you can see learn
more and go to another page and flower
tend to learn more about that product
it's super interesting we kind of
cracked a code the issue is it's a
thirty thirty thousand dollar minimum
for the industry which for a lot of
brands there's a lot of money right now
right but we are discovering brands that
do that bigger budgets a lot of
multi-state operators that want to do
things differently that you know we're
starting have more bigger conversations
about that you know we're working with
brands on creative development through
our creative agency which is flower town
agency calm and that's been kind of our
low-hanging fruit right now just based
on our expertise knowing consumer
markets helping them with strategy
helping them with campaign ideas you
know doing you know brand stories
founder stories story tellings you know
the biggest most important thing right
now for brands is to let consumers
understand who they are and tell stories
that are authentic and sincere and
things that they can connect with three
kind of on their own ties yeah yeah whoa
sorry that's such a cool journey though
yeah Wow um I'm really interested in
learning about a couple things here
let's start with some of those
strategies
when you were doing these you know these
big deals with brands and you were
figuring out the marketing and the
strategies for them and then you where
did where did your vision so tell us
about that and then also where did the
vision of the emerging cannabis market
how did how did that how did the bite
bug bite you when did it do that and yes
it's also again you know whether its
media strategy or content strategy that
all that happened at certain kind of
points my career you know when I
launched vim B and we you know became
part of mark barnard it became about
content strategies content marketing not
advertising but content marketing
reality based stories to help brands
connect with consumers through sincerity
marketing and just stories that were
important to consumers that would allow
us into their single page feed you know
called Facebook for instant whatever it
might be and in programming those
screens accordingly
Dory's that were that were passing
content along to consumers that was
helping them connect with those brands
well it was helping brand connect with
some with consumers through authentic
storytelling yeah and stories that were
in hard-hitting it wasn't advertising it
was stuff that actually that they were
interested in and then whether it was
paid for by or we could integrate a
product into a story we would always put
creative first yes with that had a
tremendous impact yes so there's this in
a sense it goes brand authenticity to
the customer brand wants to distribute
authenticity to the customer and then
have the customer go I trust that brand
I'm gonna pass along that brand I'm
gonna try that shoe and let me share it
yeah okay that's I like it I like that
that's so and that's actually that's
probably the core part of the future of
content is exactly what I mean it's you
know hey you know the day advertising
doesn't work right especially young
savvy people and even people that are
you know you know I guess Millennials
that you know the top of like 35 engines
they're just they're smart right they've
figured out a way to kind of create
their own network whether it's Netflix
or Amazon or whatever they're doing and
kind of curate their own network and
therefore you know if you're if you're
delivering ads to them or content
marketing that's meaningful that fits
their lifestyle
becomes acceptable right so that was the
key was how do we do things in a way to
let a big-box retailer or let you know a
large CPG company kind of tell stories
that are you know speaking to her or him
based on kind of their likes and their
interest and it's you know you get good
over time right you start figuring out
what that looks like in stories that
work and and things that really move the
needle but you know decision process and
then prior to that as far as media in
the cable industry was just you know we
were competing in Sprott cat stations
you had to put together media plans and
things that were impactful and could
deliver on par with you know some of the
big broadcasters yet we were we were
selling qualitative you know initiatives
and doing things differently than having
quantitative ratings connect then the
cable industry didn't do well with
rating points and with cannabis what led
me to cannabis well you know a lifelong
you know love for the plant a lot of
personal stories things that I've
encountered along the way and obviously
living in California which has had some
sort of medical or recreational for over
20 years right you're kind of in it it's
actually very mature and you get exposed
to a lot of information and it just
became a time in my career that as a CEO
on more of a visionary about so much the
operations guy right up people it goes I
go out and I look for that opportunity
based on my instincts and you know
cannabis became clear to me what was
happening and yet it was the adults
hadn't entered the room not to put down
the industry and the core of the
industry is done incredible work to get
everybody where they are today but
there's you know marketing
sophistication there's understanding of
consumer marketing there's an approach
for consumers best practices that
haven't been embraced you know that is
important to really I mean there's no
science I mean there's a science behind
marketing but it's not rocket science
right there's things in every consumer
market that happened and network and
good marketing sells things so you know
we came into this industry saying you
know what it's just you know what the
love for the planet my career everything
that I've done and rolling it into
cannabis as well as some of the people
that I love the most in this industry
that wanted to join and do this with me
it's been like you know it's just we're
having the most fun I didn't have to
interview people right I knew who I want
to work with and thank God they all want
to you know work with me and we've never
worked together because
a new venture and now we're you know
getting people that want to join us cuz
they see our vision and what we're doing
and the work that we're putting out so
it's really exciting
okay so let's hit on you have this this
thirty years of experience that is also
then being then now translated into the
cannabis industry you are then being
able to help provide all these unique
insights on the content strategy on
brands being authentic to customers in
this a new emerging market of cannabis
and there's a lot of people that want to
know exactly how to do that and so what
is going on you gave us a little bit of
this earlier what exactly is going on
that so many people aren't aware of yet
and what is flower town doing to help
address that well I mean it all comes in
the money right and every I would say
most brands in California are in a fund
raised right that they're just they're
they're trying to survive there they're
out raising money they're trying to get
some next-level whether it's going to
another state whether it's upgrading
their cultivation Center the
manufacturer whatever it might be
marketing is not a primary goal but yet
you've got componentization that's
happening right there's thousands of
brands and you got these retail stores
that have limited shelf space right so a
lot of these brands are just trying to
make it through we're you know it we
always say at flower town that you know
if these brands start working with us
twelve months ago granted we weren't
really consumer facing at the time their
world to be much different but it also
takes real money to do that even though
we've adjusted our thinking and our kind
of our budget parameters based on this
industry being so nascent and and kind
of people just getting their few of
marketing you know the big but you but
we're we always say like a month in
cannabis is six months anywhere else
even in the last month we've seen
massive changes right consolidations
happening MS OHS are buying everything
you know I went so is again multi-state
operators are you know they're just
they're becoming big quick right there
they're in an acquisition mode there
they're just you know when they're all
furtively which conglomerates that are
vertically integrated yeah which ones
would jump well I mean you know the
acreage the the crest goes the GT is the
grassroots the I mean there's just
they're they're big you know they're
brands you know retail cultivation
manufacturing I mean some of them are
twelve plus States
you know it's impressive what they're
doing you know so when we looked at what
VIN D represents a company that I built
with local infrastructure and local
expertise of market understanding and we
look at our team that we brought into
flower town which are experts and group
spending models you know whether it's
dealer associations or strategist that
work for large CPG companies that you
know just some of the most brilliant
people in the country when it comes to
strategy and we start looking at some of
these brands that are emerging that are
operating in multiple states but yet
they can't do anything nationally
because of the federal government so
they have to market state-by-state but
locals really important right so the
next phase for flower town is is
localization for platform so flower town
Chicago flower town Detroit right
because locals are really important
people identify with it and you've got
to look at each state individually
because you can't there's no national
platform right you can't do anything
nationally then you look at the MSO is
the multi-state operators and they also
need to be relevant to local markets
right once they look at their marketing
strategy it's well you know how do we do
this affordably but yet you know we need
to identify these markets because people
are sensitive whether it's skin color
accents household income you I mean you
know city versus rural whatever it might
be that there's dynamics that you can't
assume one size fits all so it's a
complicated balancing act that that we
all kind of grew up in the industry
doing so we know how to do it and now
it's about you know educating you know
brands and letting misschien our
capabilities because it's pretty unique
for the industry and things that we can
do on the creative agency side as well
as the platform side so you have to know
what the different psycho and
demographics are of people across
different states you have to know what
different brands want at just a ten
thousand dollar budget for a marketing
product or at one hundred
million one hundred thousand or a
million dollar budget you have to know
how to create you said there's
components a flower town again let's go
through the components of flower town
again so it's we have our platform yeah
flower Kem calm yes which is a
consumer-based platform and it's guiding
that new consumer from story discovery
although through the first transaction
and this means like if I have is this
everywhere from if I've never
experienced like an edible or something
all the way to like educating me on
stuff like that like here yeah but we
you know we don't use certain words
right we don't say we'd we say cannabis
we don't say joint we say pre-roll will
never show partaking we feel that way as
things normalize as in the spirits
business you know you don't show
partaking I think there's ways
consumption yeah on video or in pictures
so you know we focus on images and
storylines and titles that are
approachable to that new consumer you
know we're not going to show gabbing a
flower town it's just it's intimidating
it's it's it's a device that with a
blowtorch that you know it can new
consumers like whoa who like that seems
extreme right so we make stories
approachable but you know our approach
with flower town calm is a cannabis and
approach always right whether it's
lifestyle based whether it's educational
base there's always a canvas companion
and then the lifestyle yeah whatever
whatever it might be but it's we focus
on I like that education discovery
we're always recommend products then we
link the product pages on the platform
from there we'll help you find the
dispensary locally that we can buy these
products and then we kind of you know if
they're sort of retention or loyalty
programs okay so so I'm I'm I'm on a
flower town because of really like again
it's based on this brand that when I go
to flower town I know that I'm getting a
cannabis and experience that there's
something and a life something around
lifestyle or something around education
that I'm learning about this process
well we might even do a feature on a
retail store that we really like really
really cool experience cuz you know not
even reach a store makes it a flower
town one you have to be legal right but
two you've got to have an experience
that we deem premium right there's still
some retail stores that you walk into
the lobby and you feel like you're
waiting to see your kid in jail right
it's just they it's just there's some
guys are doing it well
and those will always endorse so it's a
balancing act and we have a filter for
products and retail that we deem kind of
good for the new consumer yeah you don't
want someone that's first approaching
cannabis to walk into one of these like
you said it does kind it's crazy like
just being behind like a piece of glass
with like a little slot underneath to
just like get something that you can't
even see at all
behind it like versus you know big
beautiful experience design that's that
is like friendly and we'll bring it out
to you we'll open it up we'll let you
little play and look at it and talk and
talk experiences that don't have tinted
windows when you drive by you can see in
the store alright that's what you expect
in any retail series right I think you
know people have been hiding in the
shadows or just being quiet based on the
vulnerability of security and different
things that you know I think that the
tides starting the turn is like
revealing the veil on the emerging
market like making it more and more
publicly facing as it progresses
removing the veil that's kind of what
you guys in a sense are ya doing
breathing we're trying to you know at
the same time and I was saying you know
some of our early revenues are coming
from helping brands through our creative
agency and and helping them with
strategy and helping them with you know
brand stories and helping them kind of
discover kind of an interesting scalable
path of assets that are repeatable and
things that are attainable based on cost
but yet you know we can we can add
volume and thought and things that help
them connect with new consumers right
because a lot of what's happening in the
industry today is a lot of brands are
focused on the retail store they're
focused on the budtender I mean even
they should because that blend Tetra
needs to talk about their product that
they're focused on kind of that that
last kind of step before purchase versus
well how do I create marketing
strategies outside the dispensary how do
I get consumers when they walk in the
dispensary to ask for my brand but is
just being told about my brand right and
sometimes bud tenders based on who's
taking care of them might skew a certain
product because you know they don't have
an interest or not and hopefully they
don't but you know certain people have
certain tastes right but some people
because all of our bodies react
differently to products need to discover
and get knowledgeable and smart outside
the dispensary and what that comes a
cost right and flower town will always
do that based on you know not skewing
any opinions based on who's spending
money with us so brands need to market
on their own but it's just brands
funding that balancing act as things are
being commoditized and it's now it's
time for brands to emerge that you know
I think some of them are starting to
realize that some of them are just
trying to make it through and get
purchased and some of them it's become
as a sprint and we're kind of in it for
the marathon because it's not a short
game it's it's definitely a long game
and it's yeah what do you recommend for
for brands trying to communicate
authentic content to customers in this
massive attention economy even in the
space at large like outs even cannabis
of course like look you know taking
really high quality pictures uploading
those to your Instagram and engaging
with the people that are commenting you
know using the right tags right maybe
starting to post videos on tic toc you
know stuff like this yeah so tell us
about well I mean I think there's a
massive issue in the industry of
recycling the core right everybody's
chasing the core whether it's publishers
whether it's brands they're in the
dispensary they're within their feeds
they're taking nice beautiful colored
pictures of that really sweet you know
but or whatever it might be but how many
buds do you want to look at you know how
are these brands building their own
identity how do they become meaningful
to a consumer how do consumers feel like
that should be willing to call them love
marks right we all have love marks in
every product category whether it's your
computer your shoes your shirt your hat
your watch your you know in cannabis
those love marks haven't been developed
because there's there's no real
consumers and that's the opportunity for
brands that get it and realize I'm going
into mark I'm going to start marketing
the consumers I want to reach that new
consumer I'm gonna define my marketplace
I'm gonna define my pricing structure I
don't even to find who I am as a brand
I'm gonna define you know my package I'm
gonna you know what does a love mark ya
look like then like it's just brand
recall right and I like I can Oh like
when you see the swoosh I like apples
your love like that's your computer sure
your phones in it is an apple - that's
just your Mac capsule but pretty much
yeah okay yeah okay right no but I'm
saying you know you're wearing Nikes
might have a deal
- but those are shoes you can identify
with right that's that's your persona at
the ball and recall when I go back to
get your pair of shoes when you go back
to get your next cannabis we've done a
lot of man on the street right because
we've got this unique infrastructure the
filmmakers all over the country and
we've done just man a street and brand
recall like hey like spit your favorite
retail store like you you know people
can't get it out of their mouth fast
enough tell us about your shoes your you
know tell us about Canada's what's your
favorite product God it's like wow wow
like people just date the brand recall
is very low I like what brand recall is
then the key you talk to people about
that's like a show - what's your
favorite interview show like if they can
pick and be like oh I love watching this
interview show then you're doing a good
job because people are you being
captivated by your that you know to get
the consumers minds and again it's not
rocket science but marketing does work
if it's done well it's a true strategy
right and it's target and again you
can't what you do in Southern California
isn't gonna work in Oklahoma right if
you're a multi-state operator or what
you do in Southern California might not
even work in Northern California I mean
saying so you gotta you gotta think
about adapting to market conditions the
household incomes to ethnicities I mean
it can get costly and it but there's
ways to do it that you can do repeatable
assets that add a little bit of local
flavor but you know locals but you know
beyond before you get to the content
strategy or I would say developing
content there's a whole brand strategy
of building that brand that identity
that is important that even if you were
at the dispensary level and a brand had
ten ten ambassadors you know if you
asked each one of those ambassadors give
us the brand story without a true brand
book or a mission statement would you
get the same story who probably probably
or not right and so you got a bunch of
things floating in the marketplace that
are confusing even the founder
themselves if they have elevator
pictures with different people are
telling the story differently you know
yeah so it's a lot of basics that it but
then you have you know Kenna's brands
that are you know if it's a ten step
process to actually selling a product
and then I have momentum I'm at Step
five
I'm not going to start over so we'll
recommend we get it will step in but we
should parallel path building some
fundamentals as you go outside
dispensaries and you start reaching new
consumers you know when you reach them
in their terms the thought process is
different there you're doing like a
massive stigma right you're dealing with
ship that is you know is just real I
mean it's real and then you're dealing
with people too that would you know take
something from me or you but they're
still not walking willing to walk into
dispensary to make that first purchase
yeah well how do you get them
comfortable with that right it's it's
all I mean we're huge about education at
the industry I mean California legalized
marijuana and there's no educational
campaign right there's nothing that's
speaking to the public I mean the state
did release a budget it's very small
it's not gonna be effective it's almost
invisible based on how expensive
California media is but you know that's
one of the biggest things is just
education and and we're believers in
Flour town that you know education is
marketing you can take an educational
idea and make a marketing campaign out
of it and it's it's not gonna scene
anyway my value to people and you become
that for every call that thought-leader
like wow that guy is holding my hand
that brand is you know there's the
element of like using flower town as a
filter the reach a new consumer and
brands getting behind us because our
voice is a voice for the consumer not
plant touching we've got a retailer
we're there to be the arbiter of quality
control and safety and Trust so the
interesting play of brands coming to our
world and reaching the marketplace that
way of you know there's a there's a an
oil brand that we're gonna do with the
vaping crisis and we're kind of just
putting ourselves right in the middle of
it right now and we're gonna do a mini
doc on from the plant all the way to
filling cartridge and what a a legal
process looks like right and but the
brand is like we don't want to release
on our own we want to really seek the
flower town yeah cuz it'll be more
meaningful it's not gonna be an
advertisement it's actually gonna be you
know an educational piece of content
coming from flower town which is that
educational platform this is big the
ideas like can you disseminate content
to people that brings them education
in value that is not trying to sell your
own agenda but rather just in a sense
you're not trying to feed them your own
product in the heads of the consumer
right yeah they're coming that that that
resource that brand that's responsible
that you're doing the educational part
so that way they themselves become more
educated through you you become the
brand that they trust and then you can
then work entrusted with other brands
and deliver content that they think ok I
trust this brand now so I'll trust this
recommendation and I'll let them into my
social feed yeah right because I like
the stories they're telling me I'm
connecting with them yeah and they seem
like they're actually have my best
interest I like how you say I let them
into the social feed because Oliver
subscribe or whatever you are generating
their own media experiences Media has
never been like this ever right and you
are curating their own media experiences
my kids my kids never watch like I mean
like what's an award show or a sporting
event but my kids watch Netflix
ya know what um they watch what they
want to watch when they want a lot and
they want to watch it and they don't see
ads and partly there's some nuance there
because the super computers pointed at
their face but of the two billion
psychrometric profiles has been trained
on uh-huh so it's there's some nuance
there your little avatar in the server
that is dean waters that gets woken up
when you log into her your Twitter feed
or whatever so Dean this has been very
interesting we asked a question at least
on the way out of every show the
question is what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world beautiful
thing in the world well god I'd be
remiss if I didn't say my kids right
just there they're beautiful and it's
doing the biggest gifts when I went on
vacation I go to beaches and I go to I
grew up surfing my whole life and yeah
that's where I prefer to put myself is
on an island somewhere on a beach and
enjoying my friends my family and kind
of doing that and
now the day I retire that's where I'll
spend my time you know doing that
because I can fill my days up but to me
that's the most beautiful thing in the
world I mean aside for my kids
yeah Thank You Dean thank you so much
for coming on the show yeah really
appreciate it and thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments bowl in the episode let us know
what you're thinking
also check out the links in the bio to
Dean's work into flower town check those
out share them more with your friends
families co-workers people online who
support a new West summit as well their
links are below support us and the other
artists and entrepreneurs and your
community support them help them grow
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world you
live your very much thank you for tuning
in we'll see you soon
thanks al Thank You Dean thank you thank
you thank you cool
that's it good
[Music]
you
[Music]